foreign
hi everyone
[Laughter]
hey
how's it going
are you live yeah oh cool
hi everybody
welcome to the the live stream it's
it's great to have her how many people
are here
can you see
um yeah all right so here we are I
thought it'd be fun Sedona and Buddy are
here as well
and um
more more like handsome man carrying
thing wow that's that's a that's quite a
bold controversial statement but I'll
take it thank you
um
I think you need to get closer to the
screen I actually don't think people
need that I don't think they're asking
for it at all
um
yeah all right how is everyone doing
um I haven't streamed since
when was it always streamed on the
second Channel but I haven't streamed
since uh we did 100k
so um am I in the process of moving on
no we we moved last year so I'm no
longer in the process but that is that
that would be on on brand for sure
uh yeah I read that okay yeah
um
that's very sweet
um not sure where your shirt is on okay
all right
all right matching
um second Channel yeah yeah go subscribe
to the second channel it's called woman
carrying man we just did a bow is afraid
review We review movies and stuff on
there uh bo is afraid
was very good
yeah we were afraid we were afraid can
everyone hear me okay by the way
mic check
oh what's your hair products oh no
that's wrong one capitalism yeah okay
um
all right third Channel
yeah I want to do a skit where it's like
every every YouTuber's second Channel
and then they just keeps creating more
channels and she wants more and more
obscure and like weird and barely
uploads
um
yeah that's how I feel about it
yeah yeah but was afraid but was afraid
it was very did you guys see Bo's afraid
I thought it was pretty good
oh what someone said I want you to be my
dad
that's not him to be my dad too that's
no that's weird
um
let's not go there that's good you're
you're the dad the dog is approved I
like Philip Roth I haven't read any Don
delillo I'm I'm I'll take
recommendations
um
Philip Roth I read plot against America
and the Ghost Writer I think it's good
um
not enough rambling is this even a
podcast yes so
few things on the list for today since
we're doing a stream
I would like to
feel weird addressing the camera but you
know I got to address the camera I would
like to talk about
um
stuff
and then
um
you know we can do a little q a since I
think that's what we've said oh I forgot
to post it on Twitter oh forget it
whatever it doesn't matter people people
don't need to see this on Twitter
um do I have a PO Box yeah we have a PO
Box uh it's in the description for every
video now I think and it's on our about
page yeah kind of checks it like every
week or two yeah
uh yeah yeah yeah
um you ever thought about streaming on
Twitch I have thought about it I just uh
you know
picking things to do with your time is
sometimes hard and um I don't know
are there any questions you see in there
we should answer yeah thanks Potato Head
for ten dollars
he said here are some more things it's
not Potato Head it's potato oh potato
a potato thanks potato we love potatoes
potato has been around forever thank you
yes thank you uh bro you're Majestic
what the hell that's really sweet
um
going to sleep but you are Majestic oh
so sweet blessed potato
um yeah I'm I'm now reading Thomas
pensions gravity's rainbow
um yeah good luck I don't know I read
the first page of it and I was like
maybe for another day it's kind of a lot
uh hey we got 383 thing heads in here is
that what we're calling them
you're tired
carriers
Oh I thought we were the divorce
Children of Divorce I thought that's
what it was oh that's right
yeah yeah Seth as a sitcom when oh well
thanks for the five that's uh a good
question you know I have been not in I
haven't been reading much fantasy lately
I mean to be perfectly honest it's kind
of um I don't know what happened it just
um
I just lost interest for a little while
and I've been reading a lot of different
stuff and I've I've just been needing to
to read shorter books lately I realized
like I've been having a difficulty with
my attention spam
um you know same goes for The Dark Tower
I actually just got to um picked I
picked up song of Susanna again
yesterday and I I read a great scene
with Stephen King so
um I'll finish that hopefully soon
was your blood runians get coinciding
with wendigoons Blood Meridian video a
coincidence
um I had that idea for that skit for a
while because I noticed you know the
popularity of Blood Meridian uh on the
internet I thought it was kind of funny
you know uh that book of all all books
it's kind of a weird you know
um oh did I miss a thing from Pandora
honey you always miss a thing I'm sorry
I love your channel wow well thank you
so much for that that's very kind you
don't you don't need to do that that's
that's sweet
um
um Blood Meridian video yeah thanks that
was fun but I did yeah so I had the idea
for the blood running video for a while
and then I saw wendigoons video and I
thought like wow it's really hitting
mainstream maybe I should do it because
at first I thought oh this little too
Niche to do like a literally me of the
judge but uh then I thought yeah maybe
it's time and um yeah people I'm glad
people are watching that
uh when am I planning to get canceled on
Twitter Twitter uh hopefully never but
you know you can't really plan that
thing I mean maybe I should try to do
that
um
what oh hey thanks for the 11 what book
needs to be movie and okay what movie
would have been a better book love you
um do you can you think of any
well we just watched where the Crawdad
thing and oh my god
well I I I read the book oh my God yeah
book would have been better as I well in
terms of like I think Blood Meridian
could be a movie but I think it'd have
to be like a really austere like
off-putting I think someone said like um
the guy who did the lighthouse could
make it or like the silence I already
asked her the silent patient yeah I feel
like they're gonna do a movie I think
they are but I think it would be a good
but also what would have been better
book you know it's funny but was afraid
would have been a good book but I like
it as a film an artistic sense too but
it's just like a lot of it's a lot it
would have been yeah it would have been
a really like it would have been like a
thousand page book
um yeah that would have been yeah that
would have been a lot uh thoughts on
mass transit I I'm good I like it good
stuff fan
um
do you have any hard realistic science
fiction that is terrifying uh as
recommendation I mean not really I I
just heard cat's cradle I wouldn't call
that hard sci-fi in the least but it is
kind of terrifying there's some
implications there Vonnegut reading for
breakfast for Champions right now and
I'm enjoying that
um
kind of look like the main character
from The Bible series
um I'll have to check in on what that is
have I read Flowers for Algernon yeah
love it love I mean I read it when I was
in like
fourth grade but you know maybe I should
check in on that again Moby Dick
reference on the wall yeah that that's
uh back back there I I love that that's
that's hand drawn by someone my mom gave
that to me she got that I think in Key
West or something but I love I love that
Moby Dick it's a really nice one
I'm not a full-time streamer I'm a
full-time uh [__] poster
um and occasionally longer videos but um
let Verner Herzog make a Blood Meridian
adaptation oh man I I love Werner Herzog
um I think you've only seen Grizzly Man
or something but um yeah I'm I'm like I
have like a lot of his movies I love
fitzgeraldo and um
Aguirre and stuff
um
the cohens funny yeah yeah the cohens
could maybe pull off a Blood Meridian
adaptation funny you mentioned the cones
I've been really getting into the coins
lately I know that's like
late to the party I love the I've always
loved the Cohen Brothers but lately I've
been watching a lot of their movies
Blood Simple I just watched Miller's
cross we both watched Miller's Crossing
for the first time
um which which I wanted to watch because
I heard it was sort of a loose
adaptation of dashiel hammett's uh red
Harvest and the glass key and I just
read red Harvest and it was fantastic
and oh I'm missing a oh yeah you're
missing a lot of stuff I'm sorry I get
caught up I get I Get on tangents
um Isaac Anderson thanks for the five
I'm on a break from stocking books at
Target I think half the books we sold
Colin Hoover she's still about a third
ring kind of disturbing I mean um I have
a lot of thoughts about Colleen Hoover
um it's interesting I mean yeah I mean
best seller kind of phenomenon
um but the thing is like
I I get her appeal I get why people like
her books when you read it it's like the
prose is so like accessible and I you
know it is hard to kind of write that
way I think to to be so accessible and
cleared I think she is a talented writer
but I do think her her stories are um
problematic and and difficult and yeah
there's issues with there but um
favorite food
I don't even I think you switch right
now you smell nice
they're probably talking about you I
don't smell myself smell
great smell like sweat and sadness
um
you guys are being way too generous
two questions have you read McAuliffe
media's angry video reviews and have you
read Darwin Cooks Parker I love you and
Nadia oh that's super sweet
um I I don't think I've seen any uh
Angry Video reviews no I'm not familiar
with that Darwin Cooks Parker oh yeah
that's I I picked up slayground the
Darwin Cook adaptation so
um I actually got into Parker through
like Donald Westlake and I'm reading the
Parker series but then I found out that
the Darwin Cook adaptations are
supremely popular and I really want to
get those um those big sets of the
graphic novels you know the big there's
like two sets of the Darwin Cook
adaptation that's one thing I want to
save up and get because
um yeah I love Parker I want to do a
full retrospective like hour-long video
on the Parker series one day when I get
through it all because I'm just such a
fan of it
um
tell whoa tell me your tell me your view
tell me your views on French new waveman
carrying thing
um
yeah that's cool
they did good with the new wave New Wave
a new wave fan of those guys
um I like truffaut a lot John Luke
Goddard I
issues with I don't know I I remember
watching weekend and just being so
pissed off maybe that was the purpose uh
I don't know but yeah I love uh Jules
and Jim I love um
I love the 400 blows
haircut when
never
or maybe sometime who knows
um yeah thank you for
reminding me uh well I can't believe one
of the best YouTube comedians is a
booktuber you thanks for the 10. and I
agree you yeah it's one of those that's
well that's very nice I don't know how
to respond I'm just gonna mutter things
and
um
dancing walking rearranging Furniture
not sure what that is in reference to
but it sounds like some kind of like a
haiku maybe thank you for the 199 of
your um of your money in euros
uh yeah
um
I almost got a job at McDonald's Friday
but crapped myself 15 minutes into
interview she noticed and kept going for
another 10 minutes I didn't get the job
huh
all right
it's interesting
story
oh definitely a real story that's a
juicy that's like a that's like a
reality TV story yeah [__] your
pants is no fun that's not a fun
experience for anybody
I don't know smavies for some people but
I don't want I feel like I feel like for
babies it's really a fun experience
because they keep doing it
um do you ever feel like Society has
brainwashed I think we should move on
um what's one book you dredge through on
first read but reread it and what's
worse or better than the first time also
thoughts on June part 2 trailer uh June
part two trailer yeah hype looks good
um I'm I actually interestingly I
thought that a book that was hard for me
to get through first was uh Dune and
then uh I read uh do Messiah and I was
like oh this is accessible and rereading
parts of June it it
um I was just too young you know at the
time uh when I read it I was in like
Middle School
um
[Music]
oh
um love you all for your unique content
for Nadia how did you decide to step
into the spotlight as woman carrying man
what was that decision like yes tell us
thank you for the file well thank you
for the five
um
I mean I think I don't know if it was
like a real decision yeah it was it was
a hard decision because we were talking
about like oh having more workload
editing I mean I edit all those videos
yeah you know myself
always biased
yeah I always if you ever contradict my
points like this yeah
I Counterpoint to this
um you know it's because Jake and I can
talk for hours and do talk for hours and
we found herself talking about like
films and books and we would just like
talk about it all the time so we're like
let's record it
and that's literally where the idea came
from because you and I
are have a hard time being productive
sometimes because we just can get into a
tangent about a subject and keep kind of
like analyzing it and talking about it
over again yeah we really can
um so yeah it's fun and we just kind of
and what's fun about it is we we don't
talk about our opinions at all until
we're filming it so we we don't really
know what we think yeah and I think
I think we're so busy that like we
chose or TV
and then this kind of second Channel
kind of makes it where we can't we like
have to watch films and TV shows which
is something that we miss doing you know
so it kind of gives you like time to
kind of breathe a little bit is this uh
actual money oh my God that is so sweet
that's it insanely generous that's
incredibly sweet you don't have to send
us any money like that but that's very
nice thank you very safe and we
appreciate it
um wow
um
uh man caring thing do you ever get
burnt out I'm yeah of course I mean yeah
I think that like um
he wants a divorce
um oh wait this is not the right place
to talk about oh you may burnt out from
the the work not me oh got it okay oh
you're such a jokester
um I yeah I mean I think burnout for
anything for any I mean anything you do
it's it's going to happen and I think
that like for how many videos we've made
on the channel and on the second Channel
I've just I don't know you just get you
just have to power through some days I
mean a lot of times I don't want to make
anything and you just
I don't know force myself
um
succession in Berry final Seasons oh my
god when we review and talk about
succession and Berry that's going to be
epic yeah I'm we're both like obsessed
with succession so um I do okay
you are way more obsessed than I am and
you got me obsessed so the thing is like
I like it gives me serious anxiety
yeah you kind of you kind of lose hope
sometimes but it's so fun Greg is like
so funny in succession
oh yeah yeah I love I love succession
um
Valdez is coming I'm happy anyone who re
if you read anything actually that'd be
fun if you would have read anything that
I'd recommend rented or we've
recommended let me know I am I'm
actually very curious you know if
someone says like hey I read butcher's
Crossing I got into John Williams
Because of You I'm that makes me so
happy
um I mean because ultimately that's what
I like I I want to do I want to be able
to get people to you know read more or
or just have a good time and and find
the joy in Reading that's very important
to me and um
I mean the the memes and the other stuff
that's also important to me because it's
just um I don't know I just I like doing
things that aren't too
serious
um
thank you for saying you're a fan of the
Lolita video I say that that actually um
I I probably said this somewhere but I
actually made that for school
and uh that that was like oh I have to
post on this Wednesday I also have this
essay do and I asked my teacher I'm like
can I do a video with us it's so stupid
but um it was so weird it was like
getting my classmates to subscribe
um but uh then it's it had like 500
views and then suddenly it blew up
um just scroll down yeah yeah yeah
yeah okay I'm sorry I'm getting behind
um
so a lot of good questions I'm sorry
guys I can't get into everything I'm
trying to um there's a lot of you here
um have either of you seen and or thanks
for the five Noah uh not sure if you all
are fans of Star Wars but I really
enjoyed it you've seen it I watched the
first couple episodes
I didn't love it I'm sorry I was I was
like it's fine but maybe I do I should
give it a chance but well I think you
would have watched it except we have
like this policy where we only watch
like certain streaming service at a time
so our like monthly subscription for
Disney plus was
um ending so anyway
um yeah oh real quick favorite director
of all time I don't have any favorites
of all time but you know I love you know
John Ford and um
Robert Altman
um
okay yeah
um have you ever heard or read Ice by
Anna Cava if so what do you think also
congrats on the Milestone love you love
you dude question mark
um thanks for the thank you for that
um that's what is Ron I'm curious what
uh currency that is uh I'm very ignorant
um I have not heard or read that book
but you know I'm I'll look it out Anna
cabin
um ice people are giving me so many
recommendations and there are quite a
few books I've read based on uh people's
recommending them a lot of crime stuff
um
and uh wait
wait what is this
huh did you just do that did you just
are you laundering money through our
channel oh
yeah
I think
that is this is the second channel so go
subscribe to the second Channel um it's
a good question I think you should like
you know do I still talk to Deborah uh
you're my new Deborah I mean you're my
you're my
replacement of your S no no no no
Deborah's Joshua we don't talk about him
we don't worry about him ever not a big
deal
um let's see
uh thanks well I don't know what that
that is I'm sorry
um
uh uh let us know what that is
um I never read
um any of your recommendations I haven't
read a full book in years but really
want to where can I start by the way
love your videos
um that's really nice I feel like I've
done a couple videos uh about this
um honestly there's nothing I can really
recommend without knowing who you are
and that's kind of a the hard thing with
like recommending books to people
they'll be like hey let me know what you
want to want you know what you want
um and like what should I read what's a
good starter book and it's just like
it's up to you you know and it usually
comes back to what you loved reading um
if you read a lot which most people read
when they were kids go back and pick up
some of that stuff or or similar stuff
or anything new like you just kind of
have to go through the course and try
new things I mean go to a bookstore read
the first pages of a bunch of books and
then pick one that sticks with you you
know I don't think people should be like
trying to lock in on a book and be like
I gotta get through this book and read
it like a torture torturous process like
I'm totally against that and I'm totally
done doing that too you know I think you
should just pick up what you love follow
what you love and if you lose interest
you lose interest pick up something new
but don't stop trying to find something
new I mean I think that's the key
um yeah Confederacy of Dunces is
fantastic
um
um thank you you're behind am I behind
I'm so sorry
um
uh uh uh uh
thanks for the 10. we appreciate that
that's uh you guys are being super kind
it's totally you guys don't have to do
that it's very kind but um and scroll
down more
um uh let's see
um poo pooping okay there's the
intellectual
um
oh thank you so much
um more booktube um
that's very nice yeah um booktube cool
seeing you move in real time that is
interesting I just wanted to say I enjoy
all your videos that's really sweet
um
how many books do I have God too many
um I keep I keep buying them
um I really do
um
um let's see I want to ask from the
woman carrying man channel uh live and
we'll ask again is real time good and
Kenny recommend it to me uh we never saw
three dots simultaneously uh
no Babu was downstairs he's just not
very potty trained yet and we're afraid
to have him on the nice carpet so
um he's he's here and he has a Conan
because he got neutered but uh
um Wheel of Time I it's hard because
I've only read the first two or three
books and I
you know I I enjoyed it and I really do
like and I stand by my reviews of it but
I just got a little burnt out of it
because they are so long and I'm
learning to discover starting to
discover that I have issues with long
books it's a long series it takes a lot
of commitment but I do enjoy a lot of it
it's a classic fun fantasy story so if
um if you want to get into it give it a
shot I actually think the writing in the
first book is really quite beautiful
um have I read David Foster Wallace I
read the broom of the system and I
wasn't crazy about it
um there's other stuff I can read
um I like a lot of what he says in his
his stuff but um yeah just I I can't
make the dive into Infinite Jest
right now
um
uh let's see
why don't you know me
I don't know maybe we should uh hang out
um
have you read Jurassic Park by Michael
Crichton it's one of my favorite books
of all time it's really good Jurassic
Park is so good I read this probably in
Middle School
um I'd be interested to read it again
but yeah it's fantastic it's actually
better than the movie it has really
gruesome scenes surprisingly the lost
world is also really good the sequel
much better than that movie
um but yeah a fan of that
um
let's see let's see let's see
are your latest Stephen King by any
chance man I wish
um I wish
Stephen King helped me get back into
reading yeah I love Stephen King
you read John Williamson focker because
of oh that's fantastic what Faulkner by
the way because um man when I recommend
Faulkner it's always hard it's always
hard because people want to read As I
Lay Dying and I'm like don't start there
I know it's short and it looks like it'd
be easy to fun read but
uh I always say light in August you know
um
let's see
um okay okay
um
sorry I'm I'm I'm lagging behind once
again there's so many questions holy
[__] okay
um thank you I love you too I sincerely
hope that you will live long healthy and
fulfilled lives you and your three dogs
think that's incredibly sweet and very
genuine and nice and um
yeah thank you yeah incredibly sweet
thoughts on catching the Rye it's a
[__] great book and people who say
it's not are
lying to you or I don't know why
um if I started one piece yet no but I
have this fantasy where I'm just going
to read the entire Series without
telling anyone and then do like a five
hour review but again these are
fantasies and likely not to happen
um
I don't know if you've ever talked music
but do you have any favorite artists or
albums you have any CDs or records
um love me back I love you and and
thanks for the five
um 50 music I mean I feel like we maybe
have talked music before but I re I read
I listen I listen to really like
dad Rock like it's embarrassing
sometimes like I love the Electric Light
Orchestra I love like 70s I love Paul
McCartney I love George Harrison I love
Tom Petty I love
all of this I listen to Elvis I mean I
go into my phases like I'm not hip to
the time God I sound like a [__] old
man
um
have you ever he has hips oh the fact
that you're saying that shows we're both
not hip okay
uh have I ever written um oh yeah I'll
get to that have I ever written um yes I
write I write a lot
that's all I will say I don't want to
you know
overplay anything but I will say he he
should he won't he's I can see him as a
future author
author because he's a really good writer
and in uh at UCLA he got his
um his street cred in creative writing
street cred
um he was um that was part of his major
was creative writing emphasis for
English so you're a writer as well
wonderful writer
um we hope we hope to publish stuff one
day you know so that's that's a you know
Big Goal
um
poop and butthole uh very wise thank you
um for that
um why don't you have more followers on
letterbox I don't know why don't you
guys go follow me on letterbox stuff I
mean I feel like a fair amount for how
often I put reviews on there I'm not on
on there all very much
um
have you gotten around to reading the
passenger in Stella marriage he had
apologies if you've covered this on your
channel and just missed it love your
channel thank you and thank you for the
10 that's uh lovely and sweet um
I have not I've I've been waiting I
honestly I don't know why but it kind of
feels like
I don't want to read it yet because it
feels like it's a culminating work for
him and I don't know if he'll publish
any more books
um so I do want to read it but I kind of
want to read like suchrey first I want
to read I finished the the you know
cities of the plan or whatever uh it's
called and read outer dark so there I
want to read some more of his work
before I get into that I feel like
that'll be a later on
um
I'm very specific about the order I read
or writers in
um I feel like
um hey thanks for the five hi Jake
congrats on the Milestone what's your
favorite Stephen King book also have you
read the expanse I have the first book
The expanse uh I think you picked it up
you were going to read it and then I
um I want to start it yeah but again
that's like a big commitment thing and
I'm kind of into shorter books at the
moment but I do want to read that soon
I've heard a lot of good things about it
um my favorite Stephen King book is
God
maybe the drawing of the three
and I realize more now that I read uh
Richard Stark that it feels so much like
a Richard Stark Parker book in the sense
that Roland is like this
sociopath monster robot just like uh
going through
um on a mission
um I just love drawing of the three it's
such a
um insane like coked out book
um
have you checked out this season of bear
yes yeah we love Barry Barry is
fantastic Barry again I mean I think it
owes a huge uh debt to Lawrence block
and the Hitman series which you should
all check out if you like Barry um so
yeah you should read Lawrence blog
and uh Master on the chat but um
they asked have you ever read any web
series oh I see it it's on the bottom
sorry oh okay um scroll down uh yeah oh
best Faulkner book um I Absalom Absalom
um but um also I love light in August
uh have you seen Twin Peaks you love
Twin Peaks Twin Peaks is yeah of course
I mean we live in uh Washington we have
to love Twin Peaks we loved it before
that too though uh yeah yeah so any web
serials no I'm sorry I have no no
awareness none
um but thank you for the five that's
that's lovely um what sort of channels
do I follow that's a good question
actually
um
yeah
um I follow I mean The Usual Suspects I
don't know there's so many I love
this is such a hard question there's way
too many I mean I don't even know what
to say I love um like Wendover I love
watching uh you know obviously Daniel
Green and Murphy and um
ah [__] I can't there's literally too
many I'll maybe I'll do like a channel
recommending video one day
um
let's see let's see scroll down okay
okay
um it's on hog oh no oh no that's not
even funny
um I actually do have a plan that is
going to be part of a video at some
point it's just been taking a while
but um I do plan on reading it so
uh I'm nervous about it let's go
um
let's see
your passion for the books you cover is
infectious also you're a funny goober
thanks hey thanks for the five I'm happy
to be a funny goober
um I'm happy to be talking about books
that's kind of you know that's that's
fun I mean I I need people to talk to
about it
um
do you ever used to do anything you've
uh now joked about in your skits love
you and your channel by the way oh all
the time I feel like most of my skits
are about like the annoying character
and any skit I do it's usually based on
me and something I did
um almost always like I just think about
cringy stuff I used to do and whatever
the ones get about music what you know
the recent one where
um the guys like
um what kind of music you like he goes
oh I love everything that is like kind
of a direct thing to one of our first
dates when I remember asking our
um like what music do you like and you
were like everything and I I was annoyed
because I'm like I just want to know
like what you like like you you know I
just get a sense of your personality but
now I go back and I go yeah I was being
such a judgmental prick you know like
it's impossible to answer that oh yeah
oh yeah and it's impossible to um
to you know even answer that question
sometimes
um
let's see let's see let's see
um love your content have you read dress
and flowers nope I have the first one I
want to read it um I've heard so much
complicated stuff about it there are
people who love it people who are say
it's problematic in certain ways I mean
I don't have a problem reading that so
um I do want to read it yeah so uh
hopefully soon
um do you ever Panic about what to write
about for skits literally every time I
make a schedule yeah I mean I do three
videos a week on the main Channel like
you're kind of um always scratching the
bottom of the barrel it feels like
sometimes but you know I've also I also
know not to judge my own
judgment on it and to just do it
whatever you know comes to mind and make
it because I I can't you know sometimes
I'm like oh this is a funny video this
will work um people will like this and
you know some people will some people
won't but um I I just think like I can't
be the judge I just got to put it out
there
um
that's my advice for anyone on on
YouTube uh by the way
um let's see 1984 did you read it I have
read 1984 a long time ago I'd be
interested to read it again though
um
your visits are perfect length to share
with my friends thank you I'm glad about
that that's good I mean I'm I really
love doing short form stuff that's still
horizontal on YouTube there's just
something because it's so different than
watching something on Tick Tock where
it's just like you know in your face you
get it immediately and I think the
packaging and like the delivery of the
joke is so different it's like just the
thumbnail and then the videos like set
up punchline it's I don't know there's a
formula that's that's kind of
a flexible and fun
um
uh let's see let's see let's see
you guys are being way too generous you
guys are crazy I'm fighting the urge to
ask you about the war breaker but here I
am thank you you know I got the
audiobook then I struggled listening to
the audiobook for whatever reason then I
got the paper back and now I'm planning
to read that more soon I don't know
again it's it's a thing with fantasy
right now it's a thing with long books
and um I I want to get it done you know
but again like as much as I the problem
is sometimes when people are like hey
you got to read this book you gotta make
this video is is that like reading to me
is something I love and it's something
that is very important to me with like
writing so they go hand in hand and it's
like I
I kind of made a promise to me earlier
in this channel to be like I'm not going
to force myself and do things that I I
don't feel like I'm enjoying it you know
I'm I was an English major I had plenty
of [__] to read that I didn't want to
read and now it's like uh yeah I mean
I'll get to it because it is something I
want to do but sometimes books just
speak to you at certain times and you
just kind of have to go with your
intuition and follow where where you
want to go and and explore that you know
right now I'm just kind of on this crime
kick and I just picked up my first John
D McDonald book who Stephen King praises
to High Heavens and um it's called The
Crossroads and I read the first Travis
McGee book and I have a lot to say but
my God a brilliant writer just
amazing amazing
um
uh considering opening in only fans no
but I do want to do a skit about oh peop
you know YouTubers or creators who are
always like jokingly teasing an only fan
like maybe I'll start and only fans uh
you should start it
you got it
anyways
that's a bad joke
that's just an awkward thing
um would you uh consider teaching
English you know I thought I was going
to be a an English teacher until the
channel kind of uh uh did well I you
know I was studying English that was
kind of like my backup
um for a while but I don't think I would
like the doing that I mean
it doesn't beat [__] posting on the
internet
um it's man carrying things play any
instruments yep I play
ah man I was marching band kid all
throughout High School I grew up playing
piano so I played piano I uh play
trumpet I played uh tuba in in marching
band The Big tuba
yeah so heavy tuba so um and baritone so
some brass instruments
um
um let's see favorite horror movie or
novel
um I would say favorite horror novel
would be The Shining favorite horror
movie
um would maybe The Shining I don't know
um I love don't look now
uh don't look now yeah I don't think
you've seen it
wow
a favorite movie
or like forced me to watch no this
doesn't really like you
I don't show you okay I I usually get a
sense of stuff you'll like and I I
usually just show you do you feel like
I'm gonna ruin it for you yeah
nice
um have I already finished reading the
Dark Tower I'm still I I got stalled in
song of Susanna and but I picked it up
yesterday again and um
I'm into it again
don't look now has a great yeah don't
look now is really good I love Nicholas
Rogue
um I like uh walk about Walkabout really
good
um
wait is the oh oh no no I don't know
what the thing is that's a good question
that's a good everyone asks what am I
carrying and I'm never going to disclose
that
um ever that's it's it's very specific
private private
information
um
what happened to the nerve I don't think
anything happened I think he still makes
videos yeah I've seen some of his videos
he does good stuff
um
he also like writes books so I think he
focuses more on that right now
um
okay hey five thanks uh I'm an English
major right now do you think it's a
waste of time I don't really have a plan
on what to do once I graduate I just
enjoy studying literature you know it is
absolutely not a waste of time
um it is actually it actually can be
quite useful also a lot of jobs when
you're applying they don't really give a
[__] what your undergrad is
um you know it depends it depends it
depends they care but if you're you know
what I did um also as a back of the way
you did was do a digital Humanities uh
minor which is data science so a lot of
and you were able to do that and you got
your job you know that way and I would
have done that uh the same way um if I
weren't doing YouTube so
um it can be super useful just remember
to do other stuff you know and um and um
I would say like you should like um
audit classes too is to see if you can't
see yourself doing something like
specifically you know
um very specific right now then you can
audit classes and you can see if you're
interested in it and then you could use
it as your minor and you could still
have that also like you can always go to
uh get your Masters or you know PhD if
you want and if you want to get
something in that field so undergrad is
not like your decider for all no yeah a
lot of people treat it that way and I
think a lot of people have a
misconception that like if you're an
English major you're gonna you're going
to be a teacher you're going to do
something else yeah and it's not the
case if you look at LinkedIn
specifically like it's English Majors a
lot of people in communication and
marketing which is actually what my job
is yeah and so it really is an array of
you know and Nadia was a like an advisor
like a student advisor for people's um
you know so you know so much yeah I when
I was at in college my job was
[Music]
what to look for so yeah I I know pretty
good about those things you do you help
me get through it all uh have I seen the
Wickham I've not seen the Wicker man uh
I would I I should that's one that I've
missed um
uh you should you should just give me
four ads before this video why that's so
weird I don't know why it's doing that
um I'm sorry
um
let's see let's see
I may be on the toilet that won't stop
me from appreciating else content thanks
um good I mean have a good time there
you know uh why did I start this channel
you know
um I started back just wanting to do
something I wanted to talk about books I
thought like that could be fun and then
I put out like a way of Kings video I
think and then you Nadia is the reason
why any of it happened because she was
like you have to
just do it like once a week just do it
um and she encouraged me because I had
absolutely no faith in the channel or
myself and then I just kept doing it
once a week and then twice a week and
then eventually three times a week and
then
um yeah so I just say like it is
persistence like obviously
like most things with YouTube you know
just being really persistent and finding
um
you know it might seem like he's making
you sound like I was being very
supportive and doing it for him but
really I just want to take all of his
money when I divorce him so
yeah and that's good for me to know now
and have a record of it yeah I just I
want him to
him to get that dough wrapped up and
then that's when I'll like leave him
um
okay all right all right
um anyways too much
um that's on Hemingway do you like
Hemingway I like Hemingway yeah I like
Hemingway very much
um I like uh The Sun Also Rises it's my
favorite one I think
um you're actually my favorite Creator
it's awesome to see you interacting with
your fans thank you that's very sweet
um
that's
that's very sweet I mean there's people
are being very nice and I've met a few
people out and about in public
um and that has been so lovely
everyone's I mean all of you are very
nice and normal surprisingly uh at least
the ones that I've I mean surprisingly
considering I mean well he's married to
me
well I meet two people and you're all
well adjusted and nice and I'm like God
I'm the weirdo I mean I am so I should
just embrace it and then usually you're
putting me on
a social event
anyways
um
uh uh uh have you ever written anything
yes
um
I have to say I absolute favorite uh
Discovery last week that's incredibly
sweet I'm curious what you discover how
many of you discovered me through like
books or through um like the skits and
what was kind of the entry point because
I'm always curious about that
um I mean I think the weird thing about
doing YouTube is that you're I have you
know hours of stuff and videos and stuff
out but it does feel so it's like a very
isolating experience because you're
experiencing it all through you know I
don't see any I only read the comments
and stuff and and that's the interaction
but it's like it's sometimes it's hard
to picture those actual people out there
listening and watching it feels very
very odd you know it's so weird
um and and like meeting people outside
it's always surprising like oh yeah
that's that's cool you know it looks
like a lot of people discovered you
through both
okay
um
I mean I guess that makes sense
um oh is there uh yeah
oh
I'm just getting behind I'm sorry guys
you guys okay books skits skits
personally uh
you know I call you my husband to my
friends oh my competition there you know
what we can all share him there's enough
meat in there skits yeah I feel like the
skits are like a a little hook to to get
people to watch the book videos
hopefully
um and the longer stuff
um I really love um doing longer videos
too is just getting myself to um I don't
know I'm hard on myself in terms of like
doing a good job so
um that's my issue uh thoughts on Robin
Hobb I really want to read Robin Hobb um
I have Assassin's Apprentice I it's I
mean I I really want to get into it but
I do feel like once I start out I'll
have trouble stopping so uh I I feel
like she's right up my alley I really
want to read her books
um do you are like uh Pink Floyd yeah
uh skid City over here that's what I say
every time you know I'm like
telling people I'm like skid City over
here come on guys
um
I discover you through Daniel's channel
so books means yeah Daniel was like
crucial uh especially in those early
stages of the channel I mean we had like
200 something subscribers and he reached
out and was like hey you're doing uh a
good job and gave me unsolicited advice
it was very nice yeah yeah Daniel's
Daniel's a real one
um
I think the first video here that saw
was this one about being grateful Dale
green stormwater yeah
I remember that was one of the ones
where I got some actual good traction on
it and you know sometimes you got to be
uh Shameless about uh getting people's
attention I mean sometimes
um but Daniel was great with that he was
very nice
um
um wait a second someone said that you
were their father Nick
I don't know if you can find it there
but what the heck is there a past that
you even told me about yeah of course I
have my other family in Mexico
well is there like a child support that
you're playing them no God no okay good
yeah
waste of money
um
yeah let's see
do I like Pink Floyd yes I thought I
answered that already I'm sorry you're
going up and down yourself
370 people here I mean yeah maybe next
time I mean it is kind of disorienting
but it's it's I I wish I had could like
go through each one you know a little
slower but I'm trying to do as as many
as I can and what sticks out to me
um
okay
do I enjoy non-fiction yep I do I don't
read it as much as I I probably should
but um I like big chunky historical
novel a historical books
um
wow Daniel's even cooler than I thought
yeah he's one of the most generous
creators out there you know for real and
um he's always you know I I always see
that as kind of like an example I want
to do the same thing with others and um
you know
um spread the spread the love
um what's your favorite skit you've done
um man that's there's so many so it's
kind of hard to answer but I think I
always like the ones that are maybe a
little like
don't don't have the tons of views you
know you want to stick out for the
little ones and uh there's one that I
love that I did not too long ago where
uh like the video it's something about
like like the video isn't super
relatable like when you show someone and
the video isn't relatable and I just
like how weird it is because I remember
filming it in the bathroom and he like
films himself and he's like yeah I don't
know I like the stupid ones um
um let's see let's see let's see I
missed something
hey thanks for the 10. uh are you super
familiar with the work of something
awful based film critic Super
MechaGodzilla if so are there other
critics any medium that you'd
recommended um
I don't know who that is I'm sorry yeah
I mean thank you for the 10 but yeah I'm
not sure are there other critics you'd
recommend
um I'm I'm I'm a big fan of critics
I mean I I like to I mean there are
people who are just like oh [__] the
critics they don't know anything but I
mean I feel like my whole like sometimes
I'm like that though I don't like the
person well there are there are critics
who are clearly like have their uh head
up their ass but
um like my whole appreciation of movies
came from like uh reading Roger Ebert
reviews like when I was you know in
middle school and I I got like all his
four-star best movie list reviews I'd
read through all of them and I'd be like
I need to see this I need to see this I
need to see this so
um yeah I like uh uh your movie sucks I
I like him because he doesn't give a
[__] about pissing people off and he's
so
um so uh specific and I disagree with
him with a lot of things but I always
love his um his passion for it and he
doesn't care about pissing off people
when he criticizes something so I love
YMS um
was a Cuban Missile Crisis progress
thanks for the five and the answer to
that is uh kind of yeah
I'll tell you I mean not while it was
happening probably but uh yeah that was
crazy it almost died everyone you know
um this is I don't even know that um I'm
sorry is there anything from a novel
that would be really hard to translate
it to other mediums movie comic Etc
um first off thank you uh second off uh
yeah of course I think there's a lot of
things that are hard but I think like
Stanley Kubrick said if it can be
thought or written it can be filmed you
know you can do it there's ways to do it
and
um you just have to be careful and for
example like where the crawdads sing We
just reviewed that on the second Channel
and I think that's a book that we
haven't posted it yet though yeah we
yeah we did we're the crawdads oh no
sorry oh no I'm my brain I've been
editing all night so um uh yeah but I
think that was a poor adaptation because
it tries to be too literal to the novel
you kind of have to it's a different
medium you know it's it's it's a tricky
tricky thing
um there's a real Joel Haver energy I
take that as a huge compliment I love
Joel Haver I think he's one of the most
uh creative and um interesting people
doing uh you know comedy on YouTube and
Just filmmaking in general I love his
second Channel he talks about like John
cassavettes and stuff so yeah I love I
love Joel he's really um really
interesting guy
um
let's see quoting the judge in the title
yeah hey thanks for the two
um
I something about I actually quoted the
judge in another skit as like a skit
about Star Wars I think and Disney says
like I will never die just something
as funny it is funny I I love that kind
of the phrasing of it there are kind of
funny like dark things in that and I
just something about that language is so
um beautiful and um
[__] weird
um have heard Ursula K Le Guin I read
the left hand of darkness and it was
excellent so beautifully written in your
Wonka video is my favorite Skip by the
way oh thank you yeah I'm glad you like
that one because I I thought like I
don't I don't know if people are gonna
get this but um
uh I've read I think the Wrath Of Heaven
the lathe of Heaven uh I I need to read
more that's she's one who's kind of a
blind side for me um I need to read more
or slakayla Gwen for sure
um this one's a funny one uh hey thanks
for the eight I just got a parking
ticket instead of paying it I'm sending
money to somebody who's giving the thing
for a woman
to pay for his divorce his impending
divorce is there something I don't know
that you know no okay
um pay your parking ticket that [__] can
add up but I appreciate the eight that's
wholly unnecessary but kind
um
um you guys are being crazy with this
stuff um you're being really generous
would you take the money to promote a
self-published book
um
Oh Oh you mean like um take money from
someone for me to promote their book um
I wouldn't do that I find that um
I wouldn't say it's unethical but it's
just it's not in my my wheelhouse it's
not something I would be comfortable
doing but um I do appreciate being given
any books because I can't promise I'll
I'll read everything people give me but
I I always try to get around to it and
um so if someone wants to send me their
self-published book please either I have
a stack over there of people's uh books
they've sent me I like reading new
self-published stuff and I I promise you
know it is on my list of stuff to get
into it's on my TBR so um but yeah I
wouldn't take I like a cash thing well I
mean also like it it probably is not as
black and white
already liked book and author with a
series like Brian Sanderson you know or
something else like that and I think
it's
a little oh you're missing couple oh
real quick what do you think of
community like the show um I love the
show
um showing someone your favorite shows
video how truthful that was yeah I I
just used Community as an example
because people say the first season
isn't good the first season's great I
love the first year I mean I love
everything about it but it's also like
nostalgic for me they shot it at LACC
and that's the campus where we've met
you know and went to school at so I mean
there's a lot of that I love about it
that's where that's where it all
happened uh this is bad advice I mean
[__] the system but yeah pay your
parking ticket uh that you don't want
that
um do you ever feel reticent on books
based on length oh for sure thanks for
the five by the way um yeah I mean there
are things that I've just noticed that
it's harder for me I can go into a book
like Full Steam and a big book and get
into it but then I just have trouble
finishing it sometimes and I have a
short attention span with books I like a
book where I can read it in a couple
days you know maybe that's why I'm So
Into crime fiction lately
um
hey thanks for the seven
um I always struggled to read fiction
and you really helped me find the types
of novels I enjoy and help me become a
rapness reader thank you that's that's
really sweet and that's what I like
really um really makes me happy so you
know thanks for that
um
your help your videos help me get more
of my DND players into reading so thanks
yeah thanks for the five that's that's
awesome um Dungeons and Dragons dragons
movie was surprisingly pretty uh pretty
good uh we did a review of that as well
on the second Channel
um
man I'm loving all these readers yeah we
got these readers in here uh
oh yeah 250k yeah thanks everyone you
know this is really sweet
um I'm I'm looking sorry guys um five
hey thanks for the five love the books
videos what horror authors other than
Stephen King do you enjoy I really love
Brian Evanson and Paul uh Trombley um
Paul Tremblay I've been trying to get I
think it was a head full of ghosts I
want to read that soon
um there's a lot more um horror fiction
I like
um
what's his name um hell house uh not
Hill house I mean Shirley Jackson yeah
but uh hellhouse is Richard Matheson
I've been trying to read more Richard
Matheson lately
um so yeah I guess that's that's sort of
sort of an answer
um what Philip K dick have you read oh
that's a good question I haven't read
much Phil okay dick uh I don't know do
you guys know where should I go with
Philip K dick I've I always heard that
his books college did you yeah what yeah
I remember you doing that
um
yeah
it's he's it's interesting interesting
like
like um yeah you guys have some lovely
um
lovely lovely comments that's that's
that's that's
Lovecraft I have not read enough
Lovecraft to make any assessment on on
his work
um
reading habits um I just go any I mean
you'll she'll tell you I just have books
and piles you know everywhere it's
I like stacking things honestly like
okay so in our own oh here we go we had
if you open our kitchen cabinets instead
of dishes
it would be filled with books because
then nowhere else to store them and we
have books like obviously here in this
room but we have books in like basically
every room because we have so many of
them and then Jake whenever he likes me
time which I endorse
um you know he goes to the bookstore
and it's like 10 books each time like
you're honey you're not gonna have time
to read all of it but then I have a
problem Letting Go book so we're really
a bad hoarder book yeah I buy them and
you keep them you know I'd get rid of
more books you know why don't you rent
them if you don't want
oh I don't know I don't know like I feel
like you're always like you may not
always have time to read so but like I
find myself like looking to the
Bookshelf being like Oh I haven't read
this let me read it now you know so I I
hate to get rid of books because of uh
I love doing the recommendation videos
yeah I'm glad you guys I just um I love
reading uh I want to read some more soon
um
uh what am I even saying I feel like I'm
babbling I love reading yeah
um read Andrew Clavin he does
hard-boiled crime mystery thrillers and
I think he's like a stuff start with the
book this book don't say a word or
another kingdom okay yeah I've never
heard of uh that person uh I'll
definitely check that out I've been just
diving into like like old school like
Travis McGee stuff um lately and and
Parker someone asked about my
relationship when demon Pazuzu Pazuzu
yeah I guess your butt buddies right
huh your buddies right with Pazuzu oh my
God that's how I got Jake are am I only
answering Book Questions no I'll take
any questions you guys want to answer
ask like genuinely
um no
[Laughter]
I like the book questions but you guys
could ask me anything like I I really
don't you can ask me about the skits
like how the skits are made you can ask
us about you know the whatever you know
our [__] toenails I don't care
um
do I do I delete junk mail
um yeah I actually used to be a horrible
with my mailbox habits where I would um
just let it go unread and I'd have like
a thousand in there and then you like
cracked down you really like every time
you look at my phone you get anxiety and
I was like okay I'll guess I'll just be
very organized
you get me to be more organized I'm it's
good but I I go kicking and streaming
because screaming because I'm I'm so um
I'm I like the
you like chaos yeah it's a little bit
Challenger I don't know how to take the
fact that you like me
[Laughter]
um
let's see let's oh what's the longest is
ever taken you've taken you to create a
skit whether it was the process of
writing recording Etc you know any like
collab with someone uh usually skits I
mean it depends if there's like green
screen or whatever like it and sometimes
like it'll take me six hours of just
sitting in this room thinking of stuff
to and usually it's just my own
insecurity and fear of going like oh
that's not a good enough idea I need
something better
um but uh
usually the filming and editing doesn't
take too long but it's like the
conceiving the ideas and if I'm
collabing I think maybe the video I did
with Daniel
um about like Stephen King books uh and
we I played Stephen King and we went
through every book
um that that took a little while
um but yeah it depends
um
do I like pickles yeah pickles are good
those are the bombs have not read
Patrick rothfuss
um I have not read uh Neil Stevenson uh
snow crash would be the one I'd read
first though I've heard a lot about that
um do I like being alive oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
if he doesn't I'll kill him so you know
oh yeah yeah
favorite film and Criterion Collection
guys I used to be such a Criterion
um uh junkie you know back in like high
school
um so I have a lot of criterions uh I'm
I'm yeah I'm I before
I used to watch so many [__] movies
like I'd watch like
constantly movies so I love movies
um
uh yeah movies there are so many people
asking you if you have a foot fetch I
think it's because I mentioned toenails
did you
do you how you like to
eat every day
you can't take her seriously guys don't
take anything she said seriously
whenever you're
like right on your mouth and you like
you know
you hoard it oh that's so weird let's
not get into that it's not true scroll
down I think do you like humorous wait
oh oh hummus yeah
favorite fast food chain I like uh
Burger King because they have like the
impossible Burger
um
scroll a little bit will you meet with
Daniel Green in person I'd love to we'd
live on both opposite sides of the
country I think we've both been like hey
if you're in this part of the country
you know but maybe one I mean one day
I'm sure we will
um
we've zoomed
squirrel my skit collaborator says yeah
he was a real one for that I appreciated
that he really uh I mean I did a favor
for him
um what did you think of Dune part 2
trailer I think it has to be about four
hours long to do it justice yeah I mean
I'm it looks good I mean it looks like
the first one I mean I I feel like it's
just gonna be as good hopefully even
better I I've only seen it once I really
want to re-watch June and then before
watching the second one but yeah I'm
excited for it
um
and squirrel
let's see let's see let's see let's see
let's see oh I'm sorry uh hey thanks for
the two what's the strangest thing in
your refrigerator
should I even say
somewhat I mean there's some body parts
in there yeah I don't know no actually I
think the strangest thing because every
time we move we have to take it out of
the freezer is it an orange you have
remember there oh that's right yeah it's
actually cute because one of our first
dates we went and saw this play in LA
and then we grabbed an orange off one of
the trees like a little baby orange and
kept it and then I didn't know until
like months and months later that you
kept it and put it in the freezer and we
still have it
it was cute he grabbed and
Andre in this like almost
in La
um and then like gave it to me which was
the most random thing ever when we just
started like we were barely going out we
were really we're really made for each
other we're both very um and then I kept
it unusual I made it I put in a Ziploc
bag and I worship it along with my God
Pazuzu and I say
merge this with this I think you need to
be sitting here and doing the streaming
because you you I think I think everyone
you you guys should have uh an audio B
full-time streamer I think that's that
would be good I would I would watch that
have you seen the Santa Clarita diet
uh where's your Babu he's downstairs
chilling I mean we would love to have
him up here for him to be up here a
little bit uh do you want to go bring
him yeah all right
uh he might need to pee first you want
to take him out uh yeah
I'm all alone
I can do anything I want now
of that off-putting
um
let's see
look at all these comments
books are mid can we can we like no
um I've been thinking of doing more
streaming so maybe we can do more of
that that could be cool
more streaming I don't know I don't know
it's weird it's like I feel like it'd be
fun to stream but like I would I just
sit here and read because that's kind of
what I do I don't really play much many
I don't play any games like ever
um
we've been together for
since 2018.
uh well it's late 2017. a ceremony
Cinema Paradiso is lovely made me cry
I haven't seen Justified I haven't been
able to find it on like a good streaming
service but I love Elmore Leonard and uh
I'm sure it's good would I consider
moving yeah we can yeah yeah we consider
moving to another country
um not for a while though
um
here's Bob
hey
watch out for the water
oh there we go
there we go there's our Babu he has his
Conan because he's still recovering from
his uh neuter his surgery he had
complications with the um well what
happened was he got neutered and our boy
our other boy dog licked his wound and
so he started bleeding so he has to have
a cone on for longer than he should
because you know
yeah yeah absolutely
um
Nadia has natural streaming Vibe that's
what I'm saying
I it's because I'm a killer
okay Kendall Roy
Psychopaths have good like extreme vibe
uh
all right I'm oh I'm behind I'm so sorry
um um um um
someone said would you be a dog who's on
hinge
um you should be a dog uh murakami I've
not read any murakami
um OMG
um he like left did you go to sleep
again he's so tired oh no he's right
here we have to be careful because he
will eat books he's eaten a couple of
our books so we have to like he likes to
pee there because it's reading material
I mean I think we can all appreciate it
you know no one likes to go to the
bathroom without some entertainment
so he likes to he likes to go do his
business right there you know uh-huh
yeah
he's such a sweetie um
I mean it was sweetie are you a good boy
yeah
Donuts you're a good girl too yeah
yeah his favorite kind of book to eat uh
tragically I had this like old
um we still have it but I have like this
old 1930s magazine Fortune Magazine and
it's um beautiful but he ate like a big
corner of it that was sad but you know
it's not his fault he's beautiful
because now you'll know he left his Mark
permanently
Nadia streaming Vibes Jake has trying to
read the menu
That's so accurate I always feel like uh
I uh I'm just like
yeah trying to discover the new menu
like what's going on here he looks at me
that way you help me you keep me on
track with stuff because I especially
during stream or in anything really I I
keep I keep him on track with even like
his voice
like when we walk I'll be like no look
at me look at me not anyone else me me
me
what I had coffee okay
um do I believe in Bigfoot yeah of
course of course
I'm into Bigfoot not in that way but you
know I mean he tells me I have a big
foot so you really know um
all right you guys are are uh coming in
with the hot good questions favorite
kind of book to eat uh the Bible
[Laughter]
um so I asked by Harry Potter but I
can't locate it but anyway oh I haven't
read uh Claire in the sun
um I would like to I read um what's his
book about the uh never let me go that
was good
um
son you have a son you have nice
Luscious Hair thank you that's very
sweet very nice and Luscious it's kind
of messy
um it is very very very lovely thanks
thanks for the two it's not good for
scratching your back though
um
I have not read behold the man
interesting interesting
okay
favorite cryptocurrency um the one that
um
is
non-existent I don't I don't think
that's fun I love uh
folding ideas his videos are [__]
amazing
um
congrats on 250k question as a fan what
hey Daniel's here
um hi Daniel uh what video of yours
means the most to you
I don't know that's hard question I mean
um
I'm really there's ones that I I liked
that are just like personal favorites
and that are like Milestones but I I
really love my videos where I can just
talk about um
books or talk about like um like I
really like the one where I talk about
like reading and uh people like losing
interest in like the standardization of
like reading and stuff so I I like that
stuff I'm proud of it but it's also not
stuff that I would love to make all the
time so
I guess I guess that's my answer
um I also like the dumb jokes
um
what's stream art it's just the thing
I'm using I'm too late I have stream
labs and stuff but I just this is so
easy to do
um
are you friends with uh better than food
um I haven't talked to him or anything
no but I love his channel I love that
guy's Channel
um I read five December's based on your
review and it was awesome thanks for
posting about it uh thank you for
reading it I'm five December so good
guys it's so good you should read it
actually
five Decembers I've seen five Decembers
no but you haven't you haven't read it
but I've seen it I felt it I've
witnessed it
what was it like having his son react to
you on stream it was actually really
scary because
um this was a while ago and the channel
wasn't as big as it was I mean I just
felt like
um like what is he gonna say and I was
so nervous and someone said that he did
it but it was funny like it ended up
being fine he was a good good spirit
about it
um
so that background music in your
sketches I use all sorts of different
stuff um I mean I've just I kind of
repeat stuff that I've had over time so
maybe I can compile a thing for that
um
what do you think about Dax Flynn Dax
limb is interesting I feel like I saw
him on the streets of LA one time and I
didn't say hi I was just like is he real
but um he's he's really interesting and
I think a very smart uh
creator
um
you went back to read anything that's
very sweet that's very sweet where's the
promise to get about tax evasion damn
you guys are like I mean I feel like my
accountant uh a tax person wouldn't be
too thrilled to for me to talk about
that so um
favorite comfort book is Cannery Row by
John Steinbeck I'm just going to say
that
um
what's something you've always wanted to
do with your channel but haven't had the
chance yet
um
there there's one my disturbing books
one I want to do there's
um
I have a lot of uh videos I want to do
that are like longer and ambitious so it
just is going to take me sitting down
and doing it really you know and and uh
it's yeah and then that's a problem
right now because I distract him so much
you know I'm always like hey me
and then he just doesn't have time for
anything but 30 seconds right now that's
definitely not the case my issue is like
um is is
um my own like being afraid of you know
doing a bad job or whatever but uh Jake
is afraid Jake is afraid
yeah
um
such a sweetie
how to publish that's
um have not read string Berg
um
that's on chess I cannot play chess to
save my life I've never been able to
play chess I suck at it
um
very season four is fantastic so far
yeah yeah
crazy so far yeah
holy like it's like went from a dark
comedy to just dark
uh yeah it is so dark
are you getting hungry I can feel it in
your face I'm I honestly feel like I'm
run like something snaps in my brain
where I feel like I'm losing my my
connection to reality so I I do feel
like I'm I'm running out of state okay
all right last five minutes because yeah
my voice is getting tired I mean that's
the thing I don't know how people can
stream for like 12 hours a day because
this is like um it's so overwhelming
there's so much information coming at
you but um hey that's what you tell me
all the time when I try to talk to you
oh aren't you so good with the
one-liners around the Dangerfield
um
what does that mean Rodney Dangerfield
you don't know Rodney Dangerfield no oh
okay he's like uh respect yeah
old comedian
um anyways uh what is that comedian that
I like that you just recently hooked me
up with hooked you up with yeah my it's
my secret affair
who did I hook you up with I don't know
who are you I don't know you're watching
other comedians besides me what the [__]
you're only allowed to enjoy my videos
we're in an open relationship
when I'll be faithful to you is you know
when you know when we rack up that dough
I can divorce you take half your money
and then marry you again and then
without a prenup well prenup on my end
you can't have my money that I took from
yours and then you know but I can have
yours and then divorce you again take
the other half and kind of keep going in
the loop
God damn you two are perfect for each
other that's my response to that too
I'm glad you guys can see it because
it's like
she I mean you guys might think like
because I I'm in the skits and stuff but
she is the goofiest freaking person I've
ever met like I'm really scary he just
says a lot of things
too you know you're making me laugh you
can't sleep with one night open all the
time and I like like stab him
uh how do you balance your long-form
book content and your short form skits
um I I don't I there's really it's
really hard to balance you just kind of
go with what you can I mean life I don't
know it's just picking and choosing your
your priorities and sometimes a lot of
times the uh I just kind of like have an
idea for a long form video and I wait
until I can get a sponsorship or
something because I I don't
I refuse to put like sponsored stuff on
like the skits uh I just I I feel like
it I just don't like the idea of doing
that um right as of yet right now hey
thanks for the two appreciate it yeah
you guys have been incredibly lovely
um this stream yes and well behaved good
good job I mean compared to me but
um someone asked about food size which I
think is an awesome question
someone said I don't think this channel
could be so good without Nadia that is a
hundred thousand percent it wouldn't
exist without Nadia because uh she was
she was behind the whole thing uh
pushing it Forward making it happen
um promoting it I mean I remember when
we first started doing the videos you
would send it to like all of our friends
and family and like videos would have
five views and I'd be like oh you gotta
stop you gotta stop but you kept doing
it and it was like really sweet but you
were just so confident in it and even
when we had so few subscribers you were
like this is gonna work out you need to
keep doing it and I'm like this
like what are you talking about and
again the only reason I did that is
because I want his money again that's
yeah just just one just wasn't sure the
intention is clear like yeah
Nadia is the best she she makes it all
happen moving songs from Spotify to
Apple music while watching this stream
started at 2500 so down to 55 thank you
hey good I'm glad I didn't know you had
to do that but uh I'm glad to have been
of use and thanks for the five that's
very nice how many books can I carry at
once maybe that'll be like a 500K
special of just me dropping a bunch of
[__] books
um
are they are they arguing yeah they're
arguing
um definitely not enough to be
considered a library
um
you guys are very sweet I mean sometimes
I think like
um you know I'm just like what's what's
going on with I mean I don't know I just
I think of the channel as just like a
fun way to put out my uh ideas and stuff
and I think the channel has a lot of
Roads that's going to take in the future
and a lot of changes and I think the
more I like look at YouTube and uh
people on YouTube who have any longevity
it's because they're always changing and
trying new things and you know getting
their voice new so I mean that's kind of
what I want to do and just kind of treat
it like a big experiment you know you
missed one up baby oh I'm sorry uh that
real that girl of yours real battle ax
love you we have another Norm Norm fan
um thanks for the two
um oh Joshua commented what the heck
what are you talking about it's Joshua I
will never die trying to take my place
to see mother
Joshua is a great guy and we have no
issue I haven't done a Joshua video in a
while that was very very
faithful yeah I mean that's good that
means you're faithful Joshua thank you
for your service
uh yeah
um
I just want to say I'm an artist I and I
like sex and drugs and depending on a
big old canvas on the floor good I'm
glad you're you're at the right place
yeah
um
longest book I've ever read
um probably a Stormlight book yeah
probably like um Words of Radiance or
oathbringer should we do it one more
question all right you got I mean
there's 300 people here this is crazy I
feel so sad that like um just like
ditching
um I
I will say Okay favorite fiction book I
don't have a favorite fiction book I saw
that question a lot but um I do have a
video of like 10 favorites some of my
favorites so um yeah you can check that
out
um but yeah I'm sorry like I I really
appreciate all of you like from the
bottom of our hearts this has been
like uh Incredible Journey I never
thought we'd get to this point and um
just like having uh such a lovely group
of people who watch and you know
interact like um you know it makes me
feel appreciated and um and yeah I mean
that's
all you can ask for you know on YouTube
We're very very lucky to be in our
position and I'm just grateful to um
yeah for all of it so
yeah I mean it's a Dream It's surreal
it's it's lovely so thank you everyone
for um being here and showing up and
here we go on to up to more further
Higher Goals I mean yeah so thank you
everyone we're gonna get some lunch
we're gonna go out Chipotle
I've been
cutting calories
um anyways thanks everyone have a lovely
rest your day and Babu and Sedona and
Buddy say love you all so yeah thank you
guys so much all right bye everyone
bye